communicating with investors this is
super important yes I switching topics a
little bit but why do you why do you
need to regularly update your investors
yeah I mean it you can also sometimes
have tough conversations with your
investors but it's it's it's hugely
important to keep your investors updated
they are invested in your company both
with their time and energy and money and
it's a great forcing function for the
founder to monthly go through whatever
those metrics are that they've you know
tried to or trying to hit for that month
and in plotting it out putting it in an
email and then sending it to the
investor who is you know has put money
into the company and wants to know what
the health of the business is it's also
important to keep them updated on a
regular cadence because you're gonna
need help at some point and maybe that's
help with a higher or help marketing
your product or maybe it's hey we're
running out of money and I don't know
what to do
so by keeping them updated regularly
they're following along on your journey
and our you know they're they're more
apt to help if they know what's going on
if they see the path to the challenge or
to the success they're just they're just
going to be more excited for you or
they're gonna be more apt to help yeah
we see this all the time with syndicates
because we have so many members in a
syndicate we might have fifty or a
hundred or a hundred 50 angel investors
invest in a company and then somebody
one of the founders says I need to meet
somebody at Disney they email that list
of a hundred investors and four people
go oh my cousin works there or somebody
who worked my last company works there
or we have a deal with them with my
venture firm or something and Boyde a
lot of times you can request something
from your investors and they will go
above and beyond we see people who
invest $5,000 in a company you know
spending an inordinate amount of time
trying to help make those companies
successful what should be in the monthly
update what are the most important
things actually so the most important
things are are whatever your key metric
is what we hopefully its revenue so yeah
what your revenue is for the month it
will be eventually by the way spoiler
alert if your startup is tracking
metrics other than revenue and earnings
at some point like when you go public
that's going to be what
when I discuss right like we're sitting
here right before Ebers gonna go public
lift just went public pinterest is going
public you know at the end of that
10-year journey of building product and
delighting customers Wall Street and
other financial investors at the end of
the line are gonna be like what's your
earnings which are a bit uh what's the
price to earnings ratio we all get
judged at the end of the day by that
revenue number you know in the beginning
there might be more important things
like how people are using the product
but eventually that will be the most
important one what are the other two you
got here absolutely so the next one
would be runway and runway is helpful
for both parties as a founder you should
know how much runway you have at all
times because it takes about six months
to raise around so if you have eight
months left you should be thinking about
starting that next fundraise last month
so it's and then the investor also knows
when you know when the founder is going
to come to them and say hey we're
raising another round can you do intros
do you want to come into this round and
then the last is the risks so whatever
your sort of current what your problems
are what you really really need help
with what's whether it's product related
or you know team related being
transparent with these stakeholders is
very very important revenue runway risks
it's just a great easy top of mind
everything else can go in there - you
can have job openings you can have
requests all that stuff but if they know
the revenue they know when you're out of
money and they know the risks they can
help I mean there could be a request in
there I put that as a fourth maybe
there's a bunch of different things you
can put there but I really like the idea
when founders tell their investors what
they're concerned about what their
blockers are what are the risks in the
business because you might get some good
feedback where you might somebody might
have solved that problem already let's
talk about board meetings here I say
start board meetings early as our next
point why is that important yes adding
governance to your company early is
important so that you set yourself to a
standard and that you be professional
yeah when you said in the early slides
in a professional tone yeah when you're
early and it's just you and your
co-founder it's you know creating a time
for the two of you to sit down and talk
about the health of the business is
crucially important and I don't I don't
believe that enough co-founders do this
yeah
and then you can also use that time to
invite you know investors who are really
involved or if you have advisers to
invite them to the meeting and for
feedback they can be observers it makes
them feel important you get excellent
feedback you get focused attention from
really smart people so it's it's really
important to formalize early and then by
the time you are raising or seed or
series a your investors gonna want a
board seat so you already have this
process going you don't have to have
these amateur board meetings the first
couple times which makes the investor
say you should have invested in this
company you know you hit the ground
running so it's it's it can be very very
helpful even if it's in the early days
even if it's a little bit more informal
but really setting the time aside you
know giving an hour yeah an hour than
enough and also requesting that your
teammates contribute to it by filling
out a slide hey you've been working on
the product design for this can you put
in everything that you've been working
on the last quarter yeah it's you know
it's anywhere from four to six meetings
a year as you as you move forward with
your company I mean it really it really
depends on what you see this as such an
amazing advantage for the companies that
do do it early that we actually started
a program where we're mentoring people
so we do a board meeting mentoring four
times a year and we have five board
meetings in a day and we let people sit
in on each other's and boy does that
help people grow up and then when you go
to your venture capital firm we've
raised five hundred and seed funding or
a million in you know friends and family
and syndicate when you go to the venture
community and you've done four board
meetings and you can send them the
minutes the board decks the projections
the employee stock option plan the
valuation the 409a
all this stuff you look like you've got
it so together that I think they're more
apt to invest because now this feels
more professional it feels more
organized and it feels less risky right
you're eliminating the risk of this
company not being high functioning so
projecting a high-functioning
professional atmosphere I think makes
more people want to be in business with
you let's go over this last point here
real quick yeah and then the last with
communicating with investors is to be
proactive with
you know target investors for the next
round I mean if you that could be
because you know you could have these
target investors because you've over
subscribed and the current round and
they they're looking to the next round
or you just know you want to be partners
with someone and you're really keen to
work with them and this means reaching
out and asking if you can add them to
your monthly updates that you're already
doing or just add them some investors
some founders just add I met with you
Jason I'm adding you and I'm just like
fine that's true
I just I just sorted its if you're in an
if you're an investor in your two
precious I'm not too worried about it I
Maia de founders is don't even ask if
you met with somebody in person just
tell them I took the liberty of adding
you to our monthly update for you know
on inside comm let me know there's a
link at the bottom if you want to
unsubscribe let me know if you don't
want to get it but could really use your
feedback in the coming months and it's
just if you're an investor it's charming
and it's free information so I look at
it like wow we have this like sometimes
people invest in companies a small
investment in the beginning so they can
monitor the company to see if they can
make a bigger investment if you're
sending me information about your
startup and I watch it go from five
thousand a month to fifty thousand a
month maybe I want to get on the train
now maybe you've proven it to me through
watching those charts and watching the
revenue in the runway and the risks
start to evolve over time alright listen
this has been amazing it went a little
bit long but I think it had a lot of
great information for people if
communications is terrible and you
remember good foundation boy that could
cost problems down the road make sure
you have your communication set up ahead
of time thanks again Ashley and Sam for
joining me and thanks to our partners
and Emmy aware and producer Jackie and
Sir Charles and we'll see you all next
time when this video starts bye-bye
[Music]